the heading i suppose you can make over
your fresh page
is the map of complex numbers that's
what you could call this
uh the mind map if you want but i'm just
gonna call it the map
of complex numbers good morning aaron
thanks for joining us
all right now um what i want to do is
kind of take you on a little bit of a
retrospective tour we have actually
covered a fair bit
of this enormous expansive topic i
wonder if you feel that way you're like
yeah man my brain is swimming in this
and what we're doing in extension one as
well not to mention all the rest of my
subjects like the difficult child of
english that i'm dealing with
you've learnt a lot and i think it's
really important you understand
number one how the pieces fit together
number two um where we go from here
and and why we go in that direction um
so i'm going to do my very best to try
and
navigate this a little bit for you we
started
uh in lesson one with this thing called
the imaginary
unit and you can put a smack bang in the
middle of your page if you like
we call it i we defined it
sort of as one of the solutions
to the equation and you could jot this
down if you wanted hopefully i'll be
able to snag some space in here
it's one of the solutions to this
equation x
squared equals negative one
we very very colloquially refer to it as
the square root of negative one
but for reasons that will become a
little bit clearer in the next couple of
weeks
um that's probably not the best
definition for it this is the best
definition for it
i is one of the solutions to this
equation an equation
to which we used to say there aren't any
solutions so we sort of broke out of the
real number space
into the complex number space right
now where did this go where did this
take us well the first place was we
realized that
these imaginary numbers when you put
them together
with real numbers so you've got your
real component there a
um your imaginary component there uh b
multiplied by the imaginary unit
these two things they fit together and
interact with each other just like
irrational numbers do right when you're
like three plus root five
these bits interact with each other but
they can't quite mix
right which is why we call them complex
numbers
in the first place that they're attached
and we introduced you know a couple
names here right we called these
rectangular uh the rectangular form of a
complex number because
when you put them on to like try and
draw where they are you get a rectangle
and we also call them the cartesian form
and we often write them as
x plus iy um to sort of reference that
fact the x and the y
they tell you where you are horizontally
and vertically
and then this took us to a bunch of
different places we had a whole new form
of numbers so the first thing that we
did with them was well can we do oopsy
daisy
can we do what we do with our regular
numbers can we do them to complex
numbers so we looked at just
adding together subtracting
multiplication
and division just the regular stuff
right we were delighted that for things
like
addition and subtraction multiplication
they more or less followed all the same
rules that our regular numbers
did except that everything ended up
being a binomial so it was a bit messier
but it worked out right
we did notice that with division it
wasn't quite so straightforward we need
to bring in an extra
tool or an extra idea an extra concept
that allowed us to conduct
division for example if if i asked you
to divide
5 plus i by say 3
minus 2i unlike with our normal
numbers that we're just dealing with you
look at this you're like i don't know
common denomin like common factors
cancelling what does it even look like
what did we do
with this number in order to deal with
it we wanted to realize this story like
the fact that the denominator is
complex gives us problems what was the
way
that we realized the denominator what
did we do to it
we multiplied say it again charm yeah we
used the conjugate right this was this
handy idea
which we borrowed back from like algebra
like simple algebra difference of
squares when you have
something multiplied by its conjugate
things things square out and that will
get rid of the
imaginariness and the complexity of our
numbers right
so so that was kind of all within uh
the the sort of basics as we were just
doing the arithmetic but then we started
to realize particularly when you add
subtract
and then we get to multiplication
shortly you can actually start to
visualize this better
right if i gave you two complex numbers
and i said add them together
i asked you what was the result and its
relationship apart from just
number crunching with what you started
with right
and we started to realize that if you
plotted these onto a two-dimensional
space good morning gentlemen which we
call the complex
plane to be distinguished from the
cartesian plane right this is not
a real number then another real number
we have real numbers and we've got
imaginary numbers right
when we put these onto the complex plane
we start to realize oh
there's um there's relationships here
for example if you could say one complex
number's here and another complex
numbers here
then adding them is like doing one after
the other and where you end up
is like doing each as a separate step
right so we very very informally
talked about this idea of a vector now
for those of you who are in physics this
is a familiar idea
but for those of you who aren't we're
going to deal with this idea of vectors
direction and and distance we're going
to deal with it more within the
extension one course
and the extension two course next year
so we'll return to this idea
then we started thinking a little
further about the relationships between
complex numbers and then how they
operate together addition and
subtraction we could plot onto here
fairly easily
but multiplication did something weird
do you remember that multiplying
by real numbers takes a number and then
it scales it do you remember that
and then we notice that multiplying by
imaginary numbers does not scale what
does it do
it's a yeah it's a rotation right it's a
different kind of transformation so
when you multiply by a complex number
you do both of those you scale in some
way
you rotate in some way and we realize
that when you're talking about rotation
you're like oh this is angles and stuff
and rectangular form cartesian form
makes understanding angles quite
difficult you've got to do this extra
work right so we realized
that um multiplication you can see i've
drawn this arrow here it leads over to a
whole different way
to write our complex numbers this is
where we introduced
this monstrosity right polar form
uh mod arg form trigonometric form
because it's in terms of
sines and cosines right uh now there's
all kinds of ideas that fit
underneath this right so this argument
that we said before
we introduced this little form of
notation arg z which is which is the
theta
in there we also notice because you can
rotate around
a bunch of different angles like 0
radians
which is on the positive real axis give
me another angle that would face you in
the same direction as zero radians
what could you spin around to get to
that two pi radians would get you there
and four pi and six pi and on and on and
on so we're like this is confusing let's
try to be less ambiguous
so we introduced this idea of the
principle argument do you remember that
i mean i've used interval notation here
just to remind you of it because from
earlier in the year
we said you can go from negative pi to
pi we don't include
negative pi because negative pi goes ooh
sorry negative pi goes this way
pi goes this way you end up on the same
spot so it's like we better work out
which one we want
we decided the positive one was better
right
that's the argument what's the other
piece in mod arg form
that's the modulus and we worked it out
using an even older piece of mats namely
what's that that's pythagoras isn't it
right because we're just trying to work
out a distance
it's the hypotenuse in a right angled
triangle and i hope you notice
that this brings us back sort of i mean
not quite full circle
but the way we get this calculate this
modulus is if we go back to the numbers
in rectangular form real part imaginary
part
okay so at this point your brain was
like all right this is this is new stuff
a lot of new ideas but at least you can
fit it together in an intuitive way it
relates to the unit circle which i
didn't draw on here
but then we said from polar form
like we all got rapidly sick of writing
r cos theta plus i sine theta we wanted
a shorter way to do it
and the way that we got there was to
explore do you remember this guy
euler's formula right and i gave you i
presented two proofs one in class
outside of class for why this bizarre
result
is true that when you raise something to
an imaginary power
it's somewhat analogous to when you're
multiplying by imaginary numbers
that makes sense multiplication indices
they're connected together
so we get this rotation around and and
introduce our third and final form not
rectangular not polar but
exponential form thank you so we can
write and this is the most succinct way
to write
a complex number we can write a complex
number in terms of its
modulus and its argument but using the
exponential function
instead of using all the trig stuff okay
now interestingly enough in our last
lesson
we're starting to get to the point where
you might notice a few of these lines
are in purple that's because we haven't
got there yet
but this is sort of the most recent
thing we did we went from exponential
form
and we realized because we know so much
about um index laws and stuff like we're
quite good at index laws because we've
been doing them for years
there's an application of it which
brings us back to the
polar form right it's this one right
here named after a french mathematician
anyone remember
the de moivre's theorem right very good
and you pronounced it right i'm so
pleased though some of you were like duh
duh
duh i don't know how yeah okay so this
result here right
demara's theorem which we started to
look at last time i'm going to go a
little bit further into
today uh this takes us back
into the the polar form right you're
like there's no ease or anything like
that we got it from exponential form
um we we got uh this guy here from from
euler's formula
but it's all cosines and sines right
okay
so take a breath right i i don't know if
this is
better or worse for you to look at all
of the knowledge that you've just
sort of developed over the last little
while and to see it is deeply
interconnected in fact there's a whole
bunch of dotted lines
that are missing from this i could have
put them in but it would just be even
more of a mess than it currently is
but essentially what we've done is we've
wanted to mrs lee's and i get you as
quickly as possible
to these three different forms
rectangular polar and exponential
and what you can see is sort of on the
periphery i'm gonna have to arrange this
better when i redraw this diagram
but as you go further out there are new
applications of each of these which
we're going to return to
something over in here which we can look
at directly from rectangular form but we
wanted to show you
that it's connected actually to
exponential and rectangle form
and this thing hanging out down here
which actually some of you have already
asked me about because you might have
encountered these ideas elsewhere and
i've deliberately said no
we're going to wait until later to learn
those but today and this is the heading
you can make
on your new page after this widow
looking map where we're going to go
is something completely out of complex
numbers again we're going to use complex
numbers to get there but it's going to
take us back into the real number world
and that is heading trigonometric
expansions we're going to get there via
de moivre's theorem okay